I gotta be completely honest I have not
heard a single thing from his campaign
like I I haven't seen any tweets I I
mean I don't even I I may follow him I'm
not sure yeah I've heard and seen
nothing you're in a bubble no I'm not in
a bubble I'm very involved
it like I I mean you know I'm not tapped
into different news sites like you are
but like I'm part of the conversation in
the dialogue and I'm not you know I
follow a lot of people but the diverse
people that but no but I think you make
a good point too yeah exactly has not
broken out into this space
is not there yet I've seen it exactly
and I agree with you I've seen a lot of
clips of him uh floating around I've
seen different public statements he's
made I haven't noticed anything
specifically from his campaign I saw him
on the beach in Miami with like a
Trump's uh when Trump was getting
indicted you know he went down and he
was speaking at a Podium
um and that's the last I saw of him so I
I think he's sucking up to Trump a
little uh no Vivek are you kidding yeah
he's a hardcore Trumper